ah the almighty anime dad mentors and
oftentimes the strongest rivals our
protagonists have after two volumes of
mentors showing off their power and
flexing i think that it's just right for
me to feature dads this time it's their
tend to shine i do agree that there may
be some overlaps in the terms of dad and
mentor still we have a whole gallery of
badass anime dads and i can't wait to
shine the spotlight on them for this
list but hey april is the start of
spring in japan so that means sakura
picnics and flower viewing it also leads
to may which is when the japanese
celebrate the prized first tea harvest
of the year that's why our sponsors
sakurako and tokyo treats are here to
bring a double header for you sakurako
and tokyo treat are subscription-based
services that will deliver you some of
the finest and most delicious japanese
snacks sakurako's theme this month is
matcha and mochi while tokyo treat will
be bringing you a sakura picnic themed
box the two boxes are similar yet
different with sakurako mainly focusing
on the more traditional side of japanese
snacks and tokyo tree giving you a more
modern experience the former will be
giving you a fair share of exclusive tea
as well as matcha themed manju mochi and
such with artisan chopsticks to top off
the list if you prefer modern exclusive
and seasonal sweet sensations over
matcha however perhaps the tokyo treat
box is for you i'm talking things like
kitkat banana caramel and red bean loaf
that you won't get anywhere else i
personally love the pine ami sakura
candy which is made exclusively for
tokyo tree subscribers so check out the
link in the description box and use code
vinnie to get five dollars off your
first box i guarantee you won't regret
spending a cent on this super good deal
and just like that let's start things
off faster and furious with hohenheim
fans of full metal alchemists will know
how big of a badass hohenheim is without
further knowledge we wouldn't think much
of this guy but i just admire the
swagger hohenheim carried when he set
out here's an al's plan to seal pride
which is ironic because throughout the
scene he stays so composed despite being
a man with little pride hohenheim is one
who easily shows off his metal in more
subtle ways that's simply his style to
never overdo things with his power best
moment for me is how he doesn't flinch
at pride's attack the biggest way to
flex your superiority is to just stay in
line of an attack that you know won't
reach you head on right really who does
pride think he is with picking his
opponent then again he really is pride
so it's a mildly assuming turn of events
knowing how things in fma turn out i'm
pretty sure this battle and what i just
said are all planned and intentional
ishin takes the next spot on the list
for most of bleach we didn't know much
about who ishin is he's just the
annoying gurusaki dad who pisses ichigo
and karin off however when push comes to
shove he doesn't hesitate in showing off
his true capabilities it's something
grand fischer finds out the hard way
it's funny because gran fisher comes out
acting or arrogant the villain was so
confident in his own abilities just
because he got a new evolution well it
sucks for him that he had to run into
one of the stronger characters in the
show and that's no exaggeration ishii
utterly wipes the floor with grand
fisher destroying him in a span of a
couple of seconds before leaving with
some choice words of his own beware the
goofy ones as they say local comedic dad
ends up being captain level all this
time and i found it interesting that
graham fisher never got his rematch with
ichigo it's daddy who finishes the job
avenging masaki
endeavor versus nomu is my next pick
pleasant may not be the best description
for someone like endeavour he's not
winning any doubt of the year awards
with his attitude but you'll be a fool
to bet against him in combat why else do
you think todoroki feels so much
pressure and hatred towards his dad if
not for his dad to be second only to all
might if you're gonna ask me to pick
just one endeavor moment to show how
strong he is look no further than the
fight against nomu it's as fiery and
intense as it ever is and for me the
most badass moment in the fight comes in
how he unleashes everything on the high
end no move overcoming even its
regeneration it's such a treat watching
him talk about beating the nomu so bad
that it can't even regenerate itself in
time before getting burned in an
almighty inferno this fight also doubles
as a redemption moment for him so that's
something to take note of as well the
scene is surrounding this humanized
endeavor in so many ways i didn't expect
to be so emotional watching him to go to
work but here we are remembering this as
one of the greatest highlights of
endeavor not just for the intensity but
for the emotions it made us feel
endeavour is no almighty but we all get
that he is a more than fitting successor
though and the way in which he
dispatched this nomu is testament to
that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
luffy has one big case of disappeared
dad syndrome at least his dad isn't dead
he's just there roaming around and
leading the revolutionary army a story
that i wouldn't mind seeing more of
however he does come in clutch a lot of
times the first time we see him take
part directly in the story we see him
stopping smoker from harming his son
it's such a simple act but it's made all
the better with the presentation the
thunder the ominous atmosphere the way
they revealed him you know dragon means
business with how he just walks in grabs
smoker's weapon like that and summons a
freaking storm to save luffy dragon
isn't one for spectacle and lots of
shouting like endeavour a while ago
still that doesn't shave off any points
in his badass score it takes a lot to be
the leader of the revolutionaries and
everything we need to know about dragon
is driven home in so little time
[Music]
it's been a while since i talked about
gintama so i want to feature umiboz
versus kamui
umibose
have quite the thorny history remember
this is a son who literally tried to
kill his dad for power so i mean that's
quite hardcore i have to say it's
strange since then the two have had
another run-in as members of opposing
forces in the rakuyo decisive battle arc
gamawi sure knew how to make an entrance
here slicing shiree into two just like
that however kamui is truly a fool to
think that those theatrics could faze
his father even after slicing off the
mountain and coming at him with the
humongous sword kamui still fails to
land a decisive blow turns out his old
man still got it and in what should have
been gamawi's showcase of power to his
dad it's the dad who shatters the sword
seizing the moment and turning it into
his showcase of power talk about a
sudden momentum shift gamut tried going
all fancy with his entrance and his
feats of strength only to have
everything turned against him is so
great to watch the succeeding fight
featuring gargura only serves to up the
ante
usagate versus ryzen is next showing us
the dad versus sun fights have always
been one of the staples in anime
ryzen is by far the strongest fighter in
the whole of yuyu hakusho there is no
other way around it honestly speaking
for all that the protagonists have
fought to overcome in the entire run of
the show until now yusuke still finds
himself demolished by ryzen when they
finally had a chance to fight the insane
part about this is that ryzen wasn't
even at full strength they fought in
such a one-sided affair but the rise in
the yusuke fought never showed his true
power that's a flex if i'd ever seen one
but it's not like ryzen was
intentionally holding back to show off
against his son he legit couldn't fight
her full strength at that point in the
story for reasons that the story soon
reveals it still makes one wonder what
full strength ryzen could have been like
or how much more one-sided the resulting
fight would have been this won't be the
end of the dads who have power the fire
eclipses their sons no definitely not
and i hope you can already guess who
else is going to be at the end of this
list
[Music]
minato versus killerby and reicharge is
a showdown that isn't talked about
enough
we take a journey back to the past for
this one to a time when minato was alive
and well and at his peak some time
before the start of the story minato had
a run-in with both rygage and a very
young killer bee the two forces
recognized each other and knew not to
take each other lightly but we all know
that raigagi doesn't back down from a
fight what followed was an exchange of
blitzes on paper reikage and killer bee
could have the advantage due to the
numbers game but minato is just that
good just that ahead and just that much
better in reflexes he made the two look
completely inferior despite them being
capable fighters minato came ready for a
two-on-one and after the exchange of
blows he sure came out looking better
the series hammers at home that minato
is the way superior fighter while
there's an argument of minato not
legitimately winning due to not killing
a or something i don't think that those
arguments hold more weight to what the
show spoon feeds us with
yoga
lastly we close the list with eugero
versus 100 cops
[Applause]
did you guess it right a few moments ago
indeed we have the almighty eugiro
gracing us with his presence atop the
list a monster of a man that barky aims
to beat eugero has had a lot of
showcases of strength in the barky anime
you could point to his numerous fights
none of which gave him any threat of
losing by the way for the list i think
the eugero taking on 100 comps is simple
and effective 100 to 1 advantage is
frankly a joke considering this isn't
the first time we've seen it berserk
ringing any bells yeah what about that
still it doesn't stop making the one man
army look completely overpowered here
eugero easily dispatches every cop in
sight using nothing but his bare handed
combat no guns no powers nothing else
needed but his sheer unmatched power in
terms of combat this is the guy that
barky aims to surpass
good luck champ you're gonna need it
and that wraps up the list of dads
showcasing their power once again if you
like what you're seeing then make sure
to use that thumbs up and subscribe
button we'll have more videos coming up
and you want to be the first in line for
those so if you haven't had enough
already feel free to check out the
channel or the vinnie tube discord links
to those as well as social media sites
such as instagram and patreon are all in
the description box don't forget to
check out our sponsors of this video
monthly japanese snack subscription
boxes tokyo treat and sakuraku links are
in the description i hope you enjoyed
this video and i hope you'll be back for
more thanks for watching
[Music]